the one of the reasons that i didn't do
shark in the following years
is because they wanted to make it more
serious and they asked me they said hey
do you want to
come back but we're going to make it
more scientific and i was like well then
you should hire somebody who knows
something about sharks
yeah but i'm just going to rule and let
me let me just go like i like
if you toss me a video let me run with
that man yeah do my thing and
i'll stay within this boundary but it's
i'm going to mess with it
dude you've meant to gel there paul yes
that's so that's why i met
paul oh well and i've known paul for a
bunch of years
the okay so we had tara read on
tara reed by herself made my show go
viral
the interview i had with her where she
thought
whale sharks were when whales and sharks
oh hell yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah so god bless her let me
tell you she was dead stairs she was
that serious [ __ ] yeah you go there's
the clip you can see
there are two parts of this clip where
she's going off
and i look
yeah i look straight into the camera
because the director is telling me
this is probably just another the
director is telling me hey hey go
she's losing it go to commercial go to
commercial and i look right into the
camera and go like this
no letters going on tv man if you're
gonna cut me off you're gonna have to
cut me off
but i i kept looking because the
director was like she's
she's losing it yeah that's what we want
dude dude so de gelder was on this like
a comic bomb
oh man this is what i'm here for the
best this is what i'm here for you mean
it's not another
stuck-up interview like no let her go
this is
it so the gelder was on the same episode
after the episode you know he's got a
fake hand but he was wearing a black
glove
so she walked up to him and she said uh
um
why do you wear that glove on your hand
fantastic and um everyone's like oh no
and so paul is a really good you know
he's a he's got a great sense of humor
he'll laugh about any he goes
uh you know i but he was just being
straightforward i got you know i lost my
hand i got bit by a shark and she goes
why'd you do that oh no
oh no yeah dude and i was just like i
wish this was on tv
but she so this is what she said he goes
launching some utterly incoherent
rambling on sharks so this is searches
so i looked up sharks on the this is
great i looked up sharks on there and i
see whale sharks i'm like
must mean a whale shark in a shark heads
or a whale and a shark had sex and i
think
well how does a whale and shark have sex
because whales are mammals sharks are
animals they're both animals they have
nothing
to they have nothing to do with each
other
uh joshua didn't bother to hold back
their smirks
so basically they're followed by sheer
margarite mockery
so basically the dolphins have sex with
each other but the sharks don't so i
thought
then how is it such a thing but the
difference is the whale shark is the
biggest shark in the ocean
he's also scary and then you have the
great white who's also
scary there are over 400 kind of sharks
with the whale shark it's kind of
interesting because he's so mean
he's like a killer but like not really
but yeah
yeah they just eat plankton and if you
run into a shark that's the one to run
into
yeah that's as you don't get swallowed
holes just stay away from its mouth
because it will open its mouth this says
we're not even gonna bother explaining
everything that's wrong with what we
said
the video is so amazing because ayan
had just been doing his sharknado tour
with her so he had a look on his face
like
uh i can't believe this is where i
am you know what i mean because and he's
like i'm sure he heard that so great
though
he was just like but and me on the other
end that's candy for me i was just like
what the [ __ ] i love it i would keep
feeding her all sorts of
sh before the show she had two
glasses of wine with two pills right
next to the
and so i was going over and she would
take a pill and drink the whole life
she's so hollywood by the way
dude i i don't know like i was like
i think i have no idea what pill that is
but
two pills and two full glasses of wine
means this is gonna be a great end of
fun
this is going to be on that show weird
you kind of know like if it's going to
be a good interview
and it's also this isn't necessarily a
show
but i'll give brian a look we've been to
it long enough or i'll give him a look
where i'm like dude
this ain't going well yeah this thing
get to current events bubba
like this is not going well or even you
know what whether it's food truck diary
something like that like you just know
you're like
i'm just like ah [ __ ] you can feel an
energy oh you're just like oh this isn't
going well yeah and they know it's not
going well and you're just like oh god
but it's one of the reasons honestly
that i love live
because people have a little forgiveness
when they know you're just weighing in
it
and they almost like to see the train
wreck especially if you acknowledge the
train
yeah it's treated when they just pass
over the train right like
have you have you seen that lady she's
interviewing
the uh commissioner of the nba and he
has a
huge nose i mean it's just what it is
he's like this yeah and she goes she she
can't help she you know
like they're getting ready to start you
know and she's sitting there and you
tell she's just staring at his nose and
she's probably going
don't say nose don't say nose don't
comment on his nose
and she goes there's something you know
like she says something about his no
off the bat about his giant nose and you
just see her like
i don't think we've ever seen her again
you know that's the mole mole
when i get off stage with the lap
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son